new at noon this is teacher appreciation
week and after a stressful school year
a special group of clark county teachers
are getting some worthy recognition
hector mejia live this afternoon near
harmony jones where one teacher was just
surprised hector
this was a way to thank new teachers who
went above and beyond during such a
challenging year
seven teachers at clark county schools
including this one are being surprised
with the new educator of the year award
earlier this morning we watched as first
grade teacher eric hufford walked out to
a round of applause
here at dondero elementary colleagues at
hufford's own family were in on the
surprise
and he says he actually thought he was
in trouble when the school principal
pulled him out of the classroom
former and current administrators along
with the grandmother of a student
nominated him
this is hufford's first year as a
licensed teacher here but he worked here
before as a substitute
the teacher says he managed to keep
students engaged
with remote learning while he went to
school full time
himself it's not just reading and
writing and math
helping them just become better people
so when i see somebody do something that
maybe they were struggling with at the
beginning of the year
and then they improve upon at the end of
the year it's the
the biggest thing last year was tough
going to school full time as well as
teaching
it was difficult
hufford says he coaches the basketball
and football teams here
we're told the award comes with a few
gift cards and some gadgets like a lap
desk and halo lighting for online
lessons
and huffert also said that he used humor
to connect with the students ccsd is
surprising more teachers throughout the
week as the celebrations
continue reporting near harmon and jones
hector mejia
8 news now